it's not uncommon to make an independent
film even a documentary and have people
tell you that you should get an agent
and start trying to break into
narratives direct Hollywood movies or
perhaps episodic television and so far I
haven't really had any interest in doing
that I why if someone were to offer me a
job
I would take it but I spent 15 years in
Hollywood I'm living on Vancouver Island
now in Canada and I'm quite happy there
so making the film was for yourself it
was for your own healing and at what
point did this cathartic vision of
making it whatever you want to call it
then transfer over to becoming something
that you wanted to actually share with
the entire world and gain it gained such
popularity I realize that hasn't
screened and the states just yet but at
what point did it turn the corner and
grow the fact is I didn't know that this
film would resonate on an emotional
level until we first screened it at a
Film Festival in June 2012 it took
approximately three years to write and
research this project and it seemed that
every other day I left my office
thinking I'd written a Johnny Cash story
and then I'd leave thinking I wrote a
personal story and the fact is I didn't
think anybody would be interested in my
story in my family story or the personal
story and indeed it's a very difficult
story to share with the world probably
especially if you're a guy having said
that it seems and I don't know why this
is but there seems to be a built-in
resentment on the part of audiences to
first-person documentaries we can write
very personal autobiographies memoirs
staged plays based on our own lives but
when it comes to first-person Docs there
is that built-in resistance and it took
a long time for me to believe that I
could tell the story in a way that
wouldn't appear to be
on my part or complaining do you think
that's why people are resistant to it
what do you think would be the reason
that people are maybe I offended or
what-have-you I was not offended by
watching but I may be well thank you I
made a point of not talking about my
feelings of my narration I used my
narration to move the story forward with
the expectation that the audience will
always tell themselves a much better
story about how you must feel based on
what you show them cinematically for
whatever reason audiences sort of face
first-person stories with folded arms
and skels on their faces saying you know
why should I spend 12 bucks and the next
two hours of my life watching this guy
deal with his problems on screen when he
should be seeing a therapist so it's a
very delicate line to walk and I walked
that line forgive the pun
you